my boobs are falling out oh my god i
feel like this is how your only fan's
career starts what's up everybody my
name is quan
i'm ty i'm a bodybuilder in los angeles
california i'm a personal trainer and
bodybuilder today i'm gonna be trying on
some halloween costumes
and apparently they're gonna be women's
halloween costumes
halloween is actually one of my favorite
holidays i dress up every year
two to three costumes my birthday is
november 1st so halloween for me has
always been an amazing fun day
halloween has always been one of those
holidays where you get to show off the
muscles and
let loose a little bit you work hard all
year long why not show it off a little
bit
i actually love cheerleaders you have to
have a lot of training to do some of the
tricks that they do
so they're kind of quite inspirational
to me this is going to be
pretty interesting oh my god oh my god
this is a little tight
we're squeezing the most work i've got
in a while
this is a little short over here okay
i'm ready
all right wow i would make a great
cheerleader oh my god
i feel very masculine and tight i
wouldn't normally wear this but i mean i
look pretty good
i mean really breathable i'll leave it
there it's breathable you can just
move around and have a good time u-g-l-y
you don't got no alibi you ugly
[Music]
oh my god this is giving me kill billbox
oh yes here we go
okay oh you wake up in the morning and
you just don't know where you're gonna
end up
all right let's check this out wow oh
wow
this is a fit this is a mood right here
i feel good
a little tight at least my legs look
okay
[Applause]
it's really to save some lives you know
just want to nurse people back to health
my boobs are falling out oh my god i'm
falling apart here
i don't know if i can actually get into
this but i will do my best
i literally busted the uh the growing
part though
we got a foot in there not trying to
take all day over here it's just a
elaborate costume i am literally
sandwiched
in this tight right there okay i think
i'm ready
i'm ready to show the world i don't
think you guys are ready for this but
this is this is what it's about right
here
yeah this is i mean
it's a look i kind of tore it up a
little bit but i feel
amazing this is great
bro jesus all right i couldn't even zip
it up
and i'm just unleashing my inner holly
berry right now like i'm just embracing
the moment here
i really give women credit for pulling
off these costumes i'm not admit it's
freeing in a way
my favorite costume of the day was the
cheerleading one
i would actually probably wear that one
out had a great time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you